This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I fell of Americans. Memorial Day is a day of ceremonies and speeches. Throughout America today we honor the death of our wars. Whatever you think about Ronald Reagan, they called him the great communicator for a reason. The unknown soldier at Arlington National Cemetery. On that memorial day, Reagan was eulogizing the remains of an unidentified servicemember from the Vietnam War.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我曾是美国人。阵亡将士纪念日是一个充满仪式和演讲的日子。今天，整个美国都在缅怀我们战争中的逝者。无论你如何看待罗纳德·里根，人们称他为“伟大的沟通者”是有原因的。阿灵顿国家公墓的无名战士墓。在那个阵亡将士纪念日，里根正在为一名越战中身份不明的军人遗骸致悼词。
The remains would be intumed alongside three other unknown service members from World War I and II and the Korean War. It was a big event. That's our own Joe Rosenberg. A horse-drawn carriage brought the casket to the tomb past 250,000 onlookers, including hundreds of veterans who emerged out of the crowd to walk behind the remains on their way to Arlington. The most powerful part though, soon Reagan talks about who this unknown soldier including hundreds of veterans who emerged out of the crowd to walk behind the remains on their way to Arlington. The most powerful part, though, is when Reagan talks about who this unknown soldier
这些遗骸将与来自第一次世界大战、第二次世界大战和朝鲜战争的其他三名无名军人的遗骸一起安葬。那是一场盛大的活动。那是我们的乔·罗森伯格。一辆马车将灵柩运往墓地，经过了25万名围观者，其中包括数百名从人群中走出来，跟随遗骸前往阿灵顿的退伍军人。然而，最震撼的部分是，里根谈到了这位无名战士是谁。
might have been. Did he play on some street in a great American city? Or did he work with side his father on a farm out in America's heartland? Did he marry? Did he have children? Did he look expectantly to return to a bride? We'll never know the answers to these questions about his life.
他可能是谁呢？他是否曾在某个美国大城市的街道上玩耍？或者他是否曾在美国家乡的农场里与父亲一起劳作？他结婚了吗？他有孩子吗？他是否满怀期待地盼望着回到新娘身边？关于他的人生，我们永远无法得知这些问题的答案。
As Reagan spoke, etched on the side of the tomb itself with words known but to God, it's all really moving, even knowing what we know now. Which is that although the person being buried that day might have been unknown to the public, a lot about his identity actually was known. The government likely even knew that he had a family who would like to have his body back, but they buried him anyway.
当里根讲话时，墓碑侧面刻着“唯有上帝知晓”的字样，这一切真的非常感人，即使我们现在已经知道了真相。真相就是，虽然那天被安葬的人对公众来说是“无名”的，但关于他的身份，其实有很多是已知的。政府甚至很可能知道他有家人希望领回他的遗体，但他们还是将他安葬了。
How to honor unidentified remains has always been one of the great conundrums of war. The Romans were fond of honoring them with an empty sarcophagus. After the Civil War, the Union buried 2,111 soldiers in a mass grave in Arlington that they purposefully built on top of Robert E. Lee's Rose Garden. It wasn't until the 20th century that it occurred to anyone to bury a single unknown soldier in a public setting. This sort of memorialization came about from World War One. This is Robert Poole.
如何纪念身份不明的遗骸一直是战争中的一大难题。罗马人喜欢用空石棺来纪念他们。南北战争后，联邦军队在阿灵顿的一个万人坑中埋葬了2111名士兵，他们特意将墓地建在罗伯特·E·李的玫瑰园之上。直到20世纪，才有人想到在公共场合安葬一名单独的无名战士。这种纪念方式源于第一次世界大战。这位是罗伯特·普尔。
He's a former executive editor for National Geographic, who wrote a book about Arlington called On Hallowed Ground. And he says World War One ushered in an era of total war and mass participation, in which the combatants on both sides were mostly ordinary citizens. Anonymous every man often rendered literally anonymous amidst the violence of the Western Front. Everything about the war, not only the numbers, but the nature of it, was dehumanizing. Nobody who went through that war was ever the same again.
他是《国家地理》的前执行编辑，曾写过一本关于阿灵顿的书，名为《神圣的土地》。他说，第一次世界大战开启了一个全面战争和全民参与的时代，双方的参战者大多是普通公民。这些匿名的“普通人”在西线的暴力中往往变得名副其实地“匿名”。关于这场战争的一切，不仅是伤亡数字，还有战争的本质，都是非人性的。任何经历过那场战争的人，都再也回不到从前了。
And there was a British chaplain who was in the worst of the fighting on the front lines named David Ralton. Ralton would spend his nights conducting funeral services over the remains of soldiers ripped apart by shell fire, often burying them on the spot, sometimes unmask and the giant craters the shells had left behind. And while he was there, he thought about how terrible it was that there were these people who were essentially forgotten buried in their graves and nobody would ever remember them, and that there should be something better than that for them. And it was around this time that David Rilton came across a temporary grave, a few miles behind the front, marked by a cross bearing the name of a regiment and the words, an unknown British soldier. And he realized.
当时有一位英国随军牧师，他身处前线最激烈的战斗中，名叫大卫·雷尔顿。雷尔顿每晚都要为那些被炮火炸得粉碎的士兵遗骸举行葬礼，通常是就地掩埋，有时是在炮弹留下的巨大弹坑中草草埋葬。当他在那里时，他想到这些人被遗忘在坟墓里，没有人会记得他们，这太可怕了，应该为他们做点更好的事情。就在那时，大卫·雷尔顿在距离前线几英里处发现了一个临时坟墓，上面立着一个十字架，写着一个团的番号和“一名英国无名战士”的字样。他意识到了。
If you had a mass grave with 2,000 people in it, then it's a mass grave with 2,000 people in it. It's not an individual who had a life. Something about having a particular person, makes it more real, more human. After the war, Railton advocated for a grave bearing the body of a single soldier to bring the impossibly large tragedy down to a human scale. The soldiers in an imidity would allow each person
如果你有一个埋着2000人的万人坑，那它就只是一个埋着2000人的万人坑。它不是一个曾经拥有过人生的个体。拥有一个具体的人，会让事情变得更真实、更人性化。战后，雷尔顿提倡安葬一名单独士兵的遗体，以将那场大得不可思议的悲剧缩小到人类可以感知的尺度。这种士兵的匿名性将允许每个人
who came to the grave to project whatever was was most important to them onto the mystery. It didn't matter if you wanted to honor all those who served, or merely those who died, those who volunteered, or those who were drafted, or even whether you were for the war or against it. Everyone was free to mourn in their own way. And sure enough, when Britain dedicated the grave of an unknown warrior in Westminster Abbey in 1920. It was an overnight success.
来到墓前的人，将他们认为最重要的东西投射到这个谜团上。无论你是想纪念所有服役的人，还是仅仅纪念那些阵亡者，是纪念那些志愿参军的，还是那些被征召入伍的，甚至无论你是支持战争还是反对战争，这都不重要。每个人都可以自由地以自己的方式哀悼。果然，当英国于1920年在威斯敏斯特教堂安葬“无名战士”墓时，它一夜之间就成功了。
The dedication alone attracted so many mourners, the line for viewing lasted 10 days. And Britain's unknown warrior wasn't the only one. Britain, France, Romania, Italy, everybody at the same time jumped on this idea. Over 50 countries would end up building similar memorials, in part because the formula was so easy to follow. All you needed was the body of a single unknown soldier. The American memorial is especially beautiful. It sits at the top of a hill that overlooks the rest of Arlington Cemetery.
仅落成典礼就吸引了如此多的哀悼者，排队瞻仰的队伍持续了10天。英国的“无名战士”并不是唯一一个。英国、法国、罗马尼亚、意大利，每个人都在同一时间采纳了这个想法。最终有50多个国家建立了类似的纪念碑，部分原因是这个模式太容易效仿了。你只需要一具无名士兵的遗体。美国的纪念碑特别漂亮。它坐落在一座俯瞰阿灵顿公墓其余部分的山顶上。
In starting in 1937, it has been watched over day and night without a single interruption by a lone guard, forever marching back and forth in front of the tomb. No one knows which service the remains are from. So instead of soldier or sailor or marine, they're simply referred to as the unknown. In fact, anything that narrows the scope of who this person could be, including where exactly they were found, is purposefully withheld from the public in order to make sure
从1937年开始，这里日夜都有单独的卫兵守护，从未间断，卫兵在墓前不停地来回巡逻。没有人知道这些遗骸来自哪个军种。所以，他们不被称为士兵、水手或海军陆战队员，而仅仅被称为“无名者”。事实上，任何缩小此人身份范围的信息，包括他们具体是在哪里被发现的，都被故意向公众隐瞒，以确保
that they represent everyone who fought. The tomb has become one of the Washington DC areas biggest tourist attractions. But in 1956, we made one small seemingly innocent change to the formula of the unknown that would end up proving tricky. We began adding a new set of unidentified remains for every subsequent war. World War 2, Korea, and eventually Vietnam. Each war would get their own unknown. Which made sense there were lots of unknowns to choose from at least at first in World War One There were something like 1648
他们代表了所有参战的人。这座墓已成为华盛顿特区最大的旅游景点之一。但在1956年，我们对“无名者”的模式做了一个看似无害的小改动，结果证明这很棘手。我们开始为随后的每一场战争增加一套新的身份不明遗骸。第二次世界大战、朝鲜战争，最后是越南战争。每一场战争都会有自己的“无名者”。这在当时是有道理的，因为至少在二战初期，有很多“无名者”可供选择。在第一次世界大战中，大约有1648名
unknowns World War two The unknowns were 8,526 a Korean War 848 and then the the last war in which we had an unknown Vietnam. 4. Thanks to improved battlefield evacuation tactics, the Vietnam War produced only four sets of unidentified remains that could potentially go into the tomb.
无名者。第二次世界大战的无名者有8526名，朝鲜战争有848名，然后是我们有无名者的最后一场战争——越南战争。4名。由于战场撤离战术的改进，越南战争只产生了四具身份不明的遗骸，可能被安葬在墓中。
And then, as more information about those remains was discovered. It was down to 3, then down to two, then down to one. One set of remains for all of Vietnam, who was unknown. That single set of remains, the one Reagan eulogized in that movie in ceremony in 1984, in which was presented to the public as the unknown soldier was referred to internally as X26. But his actual name was Michael Blassie. There's not supposed to be favorites in families, right? This is Patricia Blassie.
然后，随着关于这些遗骸的更多信息被发现，数量减少到3具，然后是2具，最后是1具。整个越南战争只有一具遗骸是“无名”的。那具遗骸，就是里根在1984年的仪式上致悼词的那一位，在公众面前被称为“无名战士”，但在内部被称为“X-26”。但他真正的名字是迈克尔·布拉西。家庭里不应该有偏爱，对吧？这位是帕特里夏·布拉西。
But the first born just has something about them. Michael Blassie was Patricia's oldest brother. He was the oldest of five actually in the Blassie family. So growing up in St. Louis in the 1960s and 70s, she looked up to him. He was actually very good at anything that he did. Trisha says that Michael was constantly bouncing between activities, mastering each one
但长子总是有些特别之处。迈克尔·布拉西是帕特里夏的大哥。事实上，他是布拉西家五个孩子中的老大。所以，在20世纪60年代和70年代的圣路易斯长大时，她很崇拜他。他实际上非常擅长他所做的任何事情。特里莎说，迈克尔总是不断地尝试各种活动，精通每一项
before moving on to the next school, music, sports. You know, I think he could have done whatever he wanted to, but then he received an appointment to the Air Force, and he fell in love with flying at the Academy. At flight school, Michael was assigned to fly a ground attack aircraft known as the A37, dubbed the Dragonfly, or sometimes the Super Tweet. It was designed to fly low over its target. Pilots loved it, because closer to the ground, the landscape
然后再转向下一项：学校、音乐、体育。你知道，我想他本可以做任何他想做的事，但他收到了空军的任命，并在学院里爱上了飞行。在飞行学校，迈克尔被分配驾驶一种被称为A-37的地面攻击机，绰号“蜻蜓”，有时也被称为“超级推特”。它的设计目的是在低空飞行。飞行员们很喜欢它，因为离地面越近，景观
rushing by, the sense of flight, speed, of combat, was heightened. To the uninitiated, of course, all these things made flying the A-37 downright terrifying. But I don't remember Michael ever saying anything about being afraid of it. And so once he graduated, it was off to pilot training. Then it from there, it was off to survival training and from there, it was off to Vietnam. And I remember seeing him get on the aircraft in St. Louis, and I remember him looking back and waving to us with that beautiful smile.
飞速掠过，飞行的感觉、速度感、战斗感就越强烈。当然，对于外行来说，所有这些都让驾驶A-37变得非常可怕。但我不记得迈克尔说过任何关于害怕它的事。所以他毕业后就去参加飞行训练了。然后从那里，他去参加了生存训练，再从那里，他去了越南。我记得看到他在圣路易斯登上飞机，我记得他回头看着我们，带着那美丽的微笑挥手告别。
And I just remember thinking, oh, we'll see him again. I think we all did. By 1972, when Michael Blassie was deployed, America's military presence in Southeast Asia was shrinking rapidly. There were fewer than 25,000 U.S. servicemen left in Vietnam, as opposed to over 500,000 who had been deployed by the late 1960s.
我只记得当时想，哦，我们会再见到他的。我想我们所有人都是这么想的。到1972年迈克尔·布拉西被部署时，美国在东南亚的军事存在正在迅速缩减。留在越南的美国军人不到25000人，而60年代末部署的人数超过50万。
The war was, in effect, winding down, but it was still dangerous and there was still a lot of combat going on. This is Bill Thomas. He's a reporter who wrote about Michael Blassy for the Washington Post. And he says that the American servicemen who remained behind were stretched then. They had to do a lot with a little. And that meant Michael was going to see a lot of combat. He arrived in Vietnam in January of 72.
战争实际上正在结束，但它仍然很危险，而且战斗依然频繁。这位是比尔·托马斯。他是一位为《华盛顿邮报》撰写关于迈克尔·布拉西报道的记者。他说，留下的美国军人当时捉襟见肘。他们必须以少胜多。这意味着迈克尔将经历很多战斗。他于72年1月抵达越南。
And by May of 1972? He had flown something like 130 missions. So virtually almost every day, he had at least one combat, sometimes two combat missions. So, but virtually almost every day, he had at least one combat, sometimes two combat missions. The A37 that Michael flew had a good record up to that point in Vietnam, only if you had gotten hit. But when they were hit, things could get ugly fast. Because it could take all kinds of fire, I mean, you're flying 400 feet in the air and you get hit, you know, it can be able to parachute out of the plane.
到1972年5月，他已经执行了大约130次任务。所以几乎每天，他至少有一次战斗任务，有时是两次。所以，几乎每天，他至少有一次战斗任务，有时是两次。迈克尔驾驶的A-37在那之前的越南表现良好，只有少数被击中。但当他们被击中时，情况会迅速恶化。因为它可以承受各种火力，我的意思是，你在400英尺的高空飞行，如果你被击中，你知道，你可能无法跳伞逃生。
So that made it very dangerous. Michael would always take off in land from a protected air base near Saigon. But his missions had him flying over a lot of dangerous places. And the most dangerous was arguably a town in South Vietnam called An Loc. In 1972, An Loc was occupied by the South Vietnamese Vietnamese military along with a handful of American advisors, but it was under siege by an invading North Vietnamese army. The siege lasted a very, very long time. It went on for months and I encountered a guy who was in analog, Chris Calhoun. And he see described it as like a scene out of apocalypse now.
所以这让它非常危险。迈克尔总是从西贡附近的一个受保护的空军基地起飞和降落。但他的任务让他飞越了许多危险的地方。最危险的可以说是南越的一个小镇，叫安禄。1972年，安禄被南越军队和少数美国顾问占领，但它正受到北越入侵军队的围困。围困持续了很长很长时间。它持续了几个月，我遇到了一个在安禄的人，克里斯·卡尔霍恩。他形容那就像《现代启示录》里的场景。
The city of Anlock was totally leveled at look like Hiroshima. This is Chris Calhoun. He was stationed in Anlock as an army ranger during the majority of the siege. And he often resorted to analogies as a way of explaining just how awful it was there. At one point, he described the South Vietnamese wounded
安禄市被完全夷为平地，看起来像广岛。这位是克里斯·卡尔霍恩。在围困的大部分时间里，他作为陆军游骑兵驻扎在安禄。他经常使用类比来解释那里有多糟糕。有一次，他形容南越伤员
with their meager medical support as looking like something out of the Civil War. At one point, he described the South Vietnamese wounded with their meager medical support as looking like something out of the Civil War. Anlock was completely cut off from the rest of the world. We got food and ammunition by parachute drop every day. We were under constant shell fire. Chris's duty in the midst of all this chaos was to call in air strikes. And it was Michael Blasie's quadrant that was providing the air support.
在医疗支持匮乏的情况下，看起来就像南北战争时期的场景。有一次，他形容南越伤员在医疗支持匮乏的情况下，看起来就像南北战争时期的场景。安禄与世界其他地方完全隔绝。我们每天通过空投获得食物和弹药。我们处于持续的炮火之下。克里斯在这一切混乱中的职责是呼叫空袭。而提供空中支援的正是迈克尔·布拉西的中队。
They were flying bombing runs over and lock nearly every day. Michael and Chris never actually spoke one-on-one. Their time there didn't quite overlap. But Chris did get to know a lot of Michael squadron mates really well. And we would talk on a radio. They'd read me stars and stripes. Stars and stripes is the US military's independently run daily paper. Why would they read you stars and stripes? Well, it was my only contact with the outside world. But in Anlock, they would be over us almost 24 hours a day.
他们几乎每天都在安禄上空进行轰炸。迈克尔和克里斯从未真正一对一地交谈过。他们的时间并没有完全重叠。但克里斯确实非常了解迈克尔的许多中队战友。我们会通过无线电交谈。他们会给我读《星条旗报》。《星条旗报》是美国军方独立运营的日报。他们为什么要给你读《星条旗报》？嗯，那是我与外界唯一的联系。但在安禄，他们几乎24小时都在我们上空。
And they kept the North Vietnamese off our back. So these were people who I owed my life to. And it was on one of these bombing runs, keeping the North Vietnamese off their backs, that Michael Blassie flew his 130-second in a final mission. We'll never know exactly what happened on May 11, 1972. Witnesses recall that day's fighting as being particularly intense and chaotic. So a lot of what we do know comes from Blassie's commanding officer, who's flying into plane alongside Blassie's. And he said, the thing he remembered most of all was how bright everything was.
他们让北越军队远离我们。所以这些人是我救命恩人。就在其中一次轰炸任务中，为了让北越军队远离他们，迈克尔·布拉西执行了他的第132次也是最后一次任务。我们永远不会确切知道1972年5月11日发生了什么。目击者回忆说，那天的战斗特别激烈和混乱。所以我们所知道的很多信息来自布拉西的长官，他当时正驾驶飞机在布拉西旁边。他说，他记得最清楚的是当时一切都太亮了。
The sky would have been filled with various planes and helicopters, each going after a separate target, but also tracer rounds being fired from multiple enemy aircraft guns. And they were taking ground fire the whole time, but because they were flying into the sun, they couldn't see where it was coming from. So this just added to the confusion of the battle. In somewhere in the midst of the blinding sun
天空中布满了各种飞机和直升机，每一架都在追逐不同的目标，但也有来自多门敌方高射炮的曳光弹。他们一直受到地面火力的攻击，但因为他们是迎着太阳飞行，他们看不见火力来自哪里。这增加了战斗的混乱。在耀眼的阳光中
and the chaos and confusion, Michael's plane was hit by ground fire. And remember, Michael's plane was designed to fly low. When he got hit, he was no more than 500 feet above the ground. hit by ground fire. And remember, Michael's plane was designed to fly low. When he got hit, he was no more than 500 feet above the ground. And he had lost control of the plane. Blosset's plane began streaming fuel, inverted, and then disappeared into the jungle below.
在混乱和困惑中，迈克尔的飞机被地面火力击中。记住，迈克尔的飞机设计是在低空飞行。当他被击中时，他离地面不超过500英尺。被地面火力击中。记住，迈克尔的飞机设计是在低空飞行。当他被击中时，他离地面不超过500英尺。他失去了对飞机的控制。布拉西的飞机开始喷油，倒转，然后消失在下方的丛林中。
And there was no distress signal, which indicates that the pilot had probably been killed instantly. Michael's plane had crashed deep in North Vietnamese held territory. A helicopter team tried to get to the crash site, but due to heavy enemy fire, they'd leave after just a few minutes, empty handed. After that, there didn't seem to be any way to get to the site or find out exactly what would have happened. Michael Blassie was declared missing in action and presumed dead.
没有发出求救信号，这表明飞行员可能当场死亡。迈克尔的飞机坠毁在北越控制区的深处。一支直升机小组试图到达坠机现场，但由于敌方火力猛烈，几分钟后他们就空手而归了。在那之后，似乎没有任何办法到达现场或查明到底发生了什么。迈克尔·布拉西被宣布在行动中失踪，并被推定死亡。
The Blassie family was informed that Michael's body would not be coming home. But with, I don't, it's the strangest thing that when there is no body, there is no gathering. When Michael died, it wasn't the first time Patricia had to deal with the loss of a close family member. Both her parents came from big families, lots of aunts and uncles, lots of funerals. And she says that anytime someone passed away, they processed it by gathering together at the funeral and just talking about the person's life, who they were, how much everyone missed them.
布拉西一家被告知迈克尔的遗体不会回家。但是，我不知道，最奇怪的事情是，当没有遗体时，就没有葬礼。迈克尔去世时，这并不是帕特里夏第一次面对亲人的离世。她的父母都来自大家庭，有很多姑姑和叔叔，有很多葬礼。她说，每当有人去世，他们都会通过参加葬礼聚在一起，谈论那个人的生活，他们是谁，每个人有多想念他们，来处理悲伤。
But this time, without a body to place beneath the tombstone, the family opted not to have a funeral. I mean, there was a memorial gathering, but it still wasn't the same. We didn't talk about it. We didn't... everyone just was... I remember it's just like quiet. And then it was just like, well, we'll go on with our lives and try to be normal. Well, it wasn't normal.
但这一次，没有遗体放在墓碑下，家人选择不举行葬礼。我的意思是，有一个追悼会，但仍然不一样。我们没有谈论它。我们没有……每个人都只是……我记得那就像是安静。然后就像是，好吧，我们将继续我们的生活，努力变得正常。嗯，那并不正常。
Patricia says that Michael's death, or rather the not talking about Michael's death, ended up putting a strain on her parents' marriage. They later separated, and Patricia joined the Air Force, eventually attaining the rank of Colonel. Life, in other words, went on, even as the topic of Michael sat undiscussed and unfinished. It was just sort of put on over on a shelf, this thing that we didn't get to deal with. And it didn't resurrect itself until 26 years later after he was killed. We realized where he was. In 1994, more than two decades after Michael had been killed, both Patricia and her mother received a phone call from a complete stranger.
帕特里夏说，迈克尔的死，或者更确切地说，是不谈论迈克尔的死，最终给她父母的婚姻带来了压力。他们后来分居了，帕特里夏加入了空军，最终获得了上校军衔。换句话说，生活继续了，即使关于迈克尔的话题一直未被讨论，也未有定论。这就像是被放在架子上的一件事，我们没能处理它。直到他去世26年后，它才重新浮出水面。我们意识到他在哪里。1994年，在迈克尔去世二十多年后，帕特里夏和她的母亲接到了一个陌生人的电话。
And he said, I'm Ted Sampley, and I am a former Green Beret who served in Vietnam. Ted Sampley has since passed away, but back then he was sort of this minor celebrity, championed the cause of Vietnam POWs in MIAs. He was convinced the government wasn't telling veterans everything it knew, and he was sort of this minor celebrity, championed the cause of Vietnam POWs in MIAs. He was convinced the government wasn't telling veterans everything it knew, and he was calling Patricia without landish theory about Michael's death. I mean, there wasn't anything in his voice that was like angry or, you know, he would just matter a fact.
他说，我是泰德·桑普利，我是一名曾在越南服役的前绿色贝雷帽队员。泰德·桑普利后来去世了，但在当时，他算是一个小有名气的人物，倡导越南战俘和失踪人员的事业。他确信政府没有告诉退伍军人它所知道的一切，他当时算是一个小有名气的人物，倡导越南战俘和失踪人员的事业。他确信政府没有告诉退伍军人它所知道的一切，他正在给帕特里夏打电话，讲述关于迈克尔之死的离奇理论。我的意思是，他的声音里没有任何愤怒，你知道，他只是在陈述事实。
But he said, I started researching who was shot down on May 11th, 1972, and, you know know what was found with them and would that be on a fighter aircraft. His evidence was circumstantial and his logic was long-winded. But he said I believe your brothers in the tomb of the unknowns. But the body from Vietnam that President Reagan had buried with pomp and ceremony in 1984 wasn't unknown at all. That it wasn't fact. Michael. At first Patricia didn't know what to make of any of this. As far as she
但他说，我开始研究1972年5月11日谁被击落了，你知道，在他们身上发现了什么，那会是在战斗机上吗？他的证据是间接的，他的逻辑是冗长的。但他说，我相信你的兄弟在无名战士墓里。但里根总统在1984年以盛大仪式安葬的来自越南的遗体根本不是无名者。那不是事实。是迈克尔。起初，帕特里夏不知道该怎么看待这一切。据她
knew, Michael's body had never even been recovered. And remember she herself was in the Air Force. So after getting off the phone with Sampley, she called up the Air Force casualty office and asked, could this be true? Could Michael be in the tomb of the Unknown Soldier? And they said by no means is there anything to substantiate that your brother's in the tomb? And I said, well, you know what? Thank you very much, because that is the craziest story that I could ever imagine that a known soldier was in the tomb of the unknowns. I mean, I don't know. That's the craziest.
所知，迈克尔的遗体甚至从未被找回。记住她自己就在空军。所以和桑普利通完电话后，她给空军伤亡办公室打了电话，问，这可能是真的吗？迈克尔可能在无名战士墓里吗？他们说，绝没有任何证据表明你的兄弟在墓里。我说，好吧，你知道吗？非常感谢，因为这是我能想象到的最疯狂的故事，一个已知的士兵竟然在无名战士墓里。我的意思是，我不知道。那是太疯狂了。
It's just, it just didn't make sense. I thought this is the best example of internet conspiracy garbage I've seen to date. This is Vince Gonzalez. He was a young reporter at CBS Denver when he accidentally came across a post Ted Sampley had made on the internet about his theory that Michael Blassie had been buried in the two of the unknowns. This was in 1997, three years after the phone call with Patricia. And he says, yeah, of course, at first he totally dismissed it. And I thought, I'm going to print it out, I'm going to show it to college classes when
这只是，这根本说不通。我想这是我迄今为止见过的互联网阴谋论垃圾的最好例子。这位是文斯·冈萨雷斯。他是哥伦比亚广播公司丹佛分台的一名年轻记者，当时他偶然在互联网上看到泰德·桑普利发布的一篇关于他的理论的帖子，即迈克尔·布拉西被安葬在无名战士墓中。那是在1997年，也就是与帕特里夏通话三年后。他说，是的，当然，起初他完全不屑一顾。我想，我要把它打印出来，当我
I visit and say, this is why we say don't believe everything you read on the internet. And I did that. I printed it out, had it on my desk at CBS, and then one evening I sat down and started reading it, and I thought, well, maybe I should check this out. Sampley had no direct evidence proving that Michael Blossy was in the tomb, but that didn't make him wrong.
去大学课堂时展示给学生看，并说，这就是为什么我们说不要相信你在网上读到的所有东西。我确实那样做了。我把它打印出来，放在我在哥伦比亚广播公司的办公桌上，然后一天晚上我坐下来开始阅读它，我想，嗯，也许我应该查查这件事。桑普利没有直接证据证明迈克尔·布拉西在墓里，但这并不意味着他是错的。
Whatever was known about the remains of the Vietnam unknown had never been revealed. It was all part of the effort to make sure that the unknown could represent everyone who ever fought in the war. But Sampley had come across some secondhand accounts, suggesting that America's only set of unknown remains from Vietnam had been recovered from an aircraft
关于越南无名者遗骸的任何已知信息从未被披露。这都是为了确保“无名者”能够代表所有在战争中战斗过的人。但桑普利偶然发现了一些二手资料，暗示美国唯一的一套来自越南的无名遗骸是从一架
that had been shot down in 1972. And he had only been able to find one missing plane that fully matched the description. Michael Blassies. What still made it hard to believe was that the government was not supposed to bury anyone in the tomb. If there was a chance he could be identified like this. So Vince called a few sources in the military, not asking any hard questions.
在1972年被击落的飞机上找回的。他只找到了唯一一架完全符合描述的失踪飞机。迈克尔·布拉西的。仍然让人难以置信的是，政府不应该在墓中安葬任何人。如果他有可能像这样被识别出来的话。所以文斯给军方的一些消息来源打了电话，没有问任何尖锐的问题。
Just wondering, almost kind of embarrassed. Could the government possibly bury a known person in the tomb of the unknowns and not tell anyone? One conversation in particular told me there was an attitude within some parts of the military that might allow something like this to happen. I called up a researcher in the Pentagon and I tried to talk really around the issue. I didn't want to let them know what I was working on, but I finally said said what if you could figure out who this was What if we could go in and identify this person and give them back to his family and his response was oh that would never happen And I said but that would be the truth and he said well the truth doesn't matter
只是好奇，甚至有点尴尬。政府怎么可能把一个已知身份的人安葬在无名战士墓里而不告诉任何人？其中一次谈话特别告诉我，军方内部存在一种态度，可能会允许这样的事情发生。我给五角大楼的一位研究员打了电话，我试图绕着这个问题谈。我不想让他们知道我在做什么，但我最终说，如果你能弄清楚这是谁怎么办？如果我们能进去识别这个人并把他还给他的家人怎么办？他的回答是，哦，那永远不会发生。我说，但那是真相。他说，嗯，真相并不重要。
He's not a human being anymore. He's a symbol in America's most sacred military shrine and we would never let that happen So I wrote down the truth doesn't matter on a posted note stuck it to my computer console symbol in America's most sacred military shrine and we would never let that happen. So I wrote down the truth doesn't matter on a post-it note, stuck it to my computer console and I thought, if there's a chance, you could figure out who this is and give him back to his family, you should do it. Vince began filing FOIA requests, trying to get his hands on any government document he could about Michael Blassy. But there were things I wanted that only family members could get, where you needed an affidavit.
他不再是一个人了。他是美国最神圣的军事圣地里的一个象征，我们永远不会让那种事发生。所以我把“真相并不重要”写在便利贴上，贴在我的电脑控制台上。他是美国最神圣的军事圣地里的一个象征，我们永远不会让那种事发生。所以我把“真相并不重要”写在便利贴上，贴在我的电脑控制台上，我想，如果有机会，你能弄清楚这是谁并把他还给他的家人，你就应该这样做。文斯开始提交《信息自由法》请求，试图获取他能找到的任何关于迈克尔·布拉西的政府文件。但有些我想要的东西只有家庭成员才能获得，需要宣誓书。
So that was when I reached out to the Blassy family. Vince got in touch with Patricia and laid out his case, fact by fact, pattern by pattern. And Vince and I started talking and I called my mom and I said, you know what? It's somebody. And if it's Michael, you know, we need to pursue it. Which eventually gave Vince the leeway to file yet another FOIA request. Nothing special. Just some documents related to Michael Blassie from an Air Force base in Texas.
所以那时我联系了布拉西一家。文斯联系了帕特里夏，事实胜于雄辩地陈述了他的理由。文斯和我开始交谈，我给妈妈打了电话，我说，你知道吗？那是某个人。如果那是迈克尔，你知道，我们需要追查它。这最终给了文斯提交另一个《信息自由法》请求的余地。没什么特别的。只是德克萨斯州一个空军基地关于迈克尔·布拉西的一些文件。
Not mentioning the tomb, not mentioning the unknown soldier, just asking for anything with Michael Blassie's name in it. And I got back this really thick envelope, a padded envelope, which is more than I think I'd gotten back from any other request. And I was actually back in Denver at that point, sitting in the newsroom, and I opened it up, and I was paging through it, page after page,
没有提到墓地，没有提到无名战士，只是要求任何带有迈克尔·布拉西名字的东西。我收到了一个非常厚的信封，一个带衬垫的信封，这比我想象中从任何其他请求中收到的都要多。当时我实际上回到了丹佛，坐在新闻编辑室里，我打开它，一页一页地翻阅，
and going, oh my god, this is it. Because this wasn't just some small file containing a good lead or a tantalizing clue. These were military documents showing the entire unknown soldier selection process. When combined with his earlier research, the documents Vince Gonzales now held in his hands, painted a nearly complete picture of what the government knew regarding the identity of the unknown soldier, starting with something very important that they had known almost from the beginning.
然后说，天哪，就是这个。因为这不仅仅是一些包含好线索或诱人提示的小文件。这些是显示整个无名战士挑选过程的军事文件。当与他早期的研究结合起来时，文斯·冈萨雷斯现在手中的文件描绘了一幅几乎完整的图景，关于政府对无名战士身份的了解，从他们几乎从一开始就知道的一件非常重要的事情开始。
That Michael Blassey's remains had been recovered in Vietnam, and that they'd been recovered by Chris Calhoun, the Army Ranger stationed in the unlock. You know, I don't really know exactly what went down, but I do know that everything pointed to me. Now, remember Calhoun didn't know Blassey personally, but he was friends with a bunch of the other pilots in Michael Squadron. They were the guys reading the newspaper to Calhoun over the radio, and it was on one of those lonely nights just chatting that they started telling him about Michael. The
迈克尔·布拉西的遗骸在越南被找回，而且是被驻扎在安禄的陆军游骑兵克里斯·卡尔霍恩找回的。你知道，我真的不知道到底发生了什么，但我确实知道一切都指向我。现在，记住卡尔霍恩并不认识布拉西，但他和迈克尔中队的许多其他飞行员是朋友。他们就是那些通过无线电给卡尔霍恩读报纸的人，就在那些孤独的夜晚聊天时，他们开始告诉他关于迈克尔的事。
only thing I knew was they asked me that one of their squadron mates had been shot down. They gave me the coordinates and they wanted to know if we could get the body back. This was in October of 1972, over five months since Blassey's plane had disappeared into the jungle. They knew they were asking a lot. So I think if that rapport wasn't there, then the request would have never come and I would have never acted on it. Chris took the matter to his regimental commander who assembled a special South Vietnamese patrol
我唯一知道的是，他们问我，他们中队的一名战友被击落了。他们给了我坐标，他们想知道我们是否能找回遗体。那是在1972年10月，距离布拉西的飞机消失在丛林中已经过去了五个多月。他们知道他们要求很高。所以我认为如果那种融洽的关系不存在，那么请求就不会到来，我也永远不会采取行动。克里斯把这件事带给了他的团长，团长组建了一支特殊的南越巡逻队
dressed up as the enemy. In North Vietnamese uniforms with North Vietnamese weapons and they went out in No Man's land and they found the wreckage and they brought back to me what was left of the remains of Michael Blassy in a black plastic bag. The remains did not consist of much, just six bones, but they also brought back other evidence. An uninflated life raft was serial numbers, a parachute, part of Michael's flight suit, and critically his wallet. And that was a good shape. Pictures of him, pictures of Michael's flight suit, and critically his wallet. And that was good shape. Pictures of him, pictures of his family, pictures of his sister. There was no question.
穿着敌人的衣服。穿着北越制服，带着北越武器，他们进入了无人区，找到了残骸，并把迈克尔·布拉西遗骸的残余部分装在一个黑色塑料袋里带回给我。遗骸不多，只有六块骨头，但他们还带回了其他证据。一个未充气的救生筏，上面有序列号、降落伞、迈克尔飞行服的一部分，最重要的是他的钱包。而且保存完好。他的照片，迈克尔的照片，他家人的照片，他妹妹的照片。毫无疑问。
The remains were Michael's. Chris then handed the bag with everything in it, off to the crew chief of the week's one outgoing helicopter. But he got the bag. The crew chief got the bag. And when you saw the remains, I go away in the chopper. I mean, what was your... Well, we were sending him home to his family.
遗骸是迈克尔的。克里斯随后把装有所有东西的袋子交给了那周即将离开的直升机的机长。但他拿到了袋子。机长拿到了袋子。当你看到遗骸时，我坐直升机离开。我的意思是，你的……嗯，我们把他送回家给他的家人。
You know, we were doing what was right. And of course, those South Vietnamese risks are lives to, you know. Get his body from that wreckage. And he deserved to go home. After that, Christa just assumed that Michael's remains would be returning to his family. But according to Vince's documents, that's not what happened. The remains, along with the survival gear, would eventually arrive at the Army's central identification laboratory in Hawaii.
你知道，我们在做正确的事。当然，那些南越人冒着生命危险，你知道。从残骸中找回他的遗体。他理应回家。在那之后，克里斯只是认为迈克尔的遗骸会回到他的家人身边。但根据文斯的文件，情况并非如此。遗骸连同生存装备最终抵达了位于夏威夷的陆军中央鉴定实验室。
But not before the wallet, containing the ID that could length the bones to Blassy went missing. Even though he knew about the missing wallet, the head of the lab using now outdated techniques determined that the remains did not match Michael Blassy's physical description. Instead, they were simply designated as BTB, believed to be Michael Blassy. Without a positive match due to army policy, the Blassie family could not even be told that any remains had been found. Meanwhile, pressure began to mount in the Pentagon
但在那之前，包含可以将骨头与布拉西联系起来的身份证件的钱包不见了。尽管他知道钱包丢失的事，但实验室负责人使用当时过时的技术确定遗骸与迈克尔·布拉西的身体描述不符。相反，他们被简单地指定为BTB，即“被认为是迈克尔·布拉西”。由于陆军政策，在没有确切匹配的情况下，甚至不能告诉布拉西一家已经发现了任何遗骸。与此同时，五角大楼开始面临压力
to place a veteran from Vietnam in the tomb of the unknown soldier. It was politics, but it was also patriotism. While there was a crass political angle to do this, to make nice with the Vietnam veterans, there was also a feeling of we need to get someone in that tomb so the nation can heal around this issue. But by the 1980s, there was only one set of unidentified remains left.
将一名越战老兵安葬在无名战士墓中。这是政治，但也是爱国主义。虽然这样做有一个粗俗的政治角度，即为了与越战老兵搞好关系，但也有一种感觉，我们需要让某个人进入那个墓，这样国家才能围绕这个问题愈合。但到了20世纪80年代，只剩下一套身份不明的遗骸了。
The ones labeled believe to be Michael Blassie. So in 1980, the lab was ordered to strip their remains of their formal connection with Blassie and give them the anonymous designation X-26. And in 1984, with the Reagan administration eager to put someone on the tune before election day, they were told to prepare X-26 for burial. And I spoke with technicians at the Army Lab later who said, we gave them every answer possible to say, don't do this. The technology is coming. This is not an unknown set of remains. The lab technicians told the Pentagon
那些被标记为“被认为是迈克尔·布拉西”的遗骸。因此，在1980年，实验室被命令剥夺这些遗骸与布拉西的正式联系，并给他们匿名代号“X-26”。1984年，里根政府急于在选举日前将某人安葬在墓中，他们被告知准备将X-26安葬。后来我与陆军实验室的技术人员交谈，他们说，我们给了他们所有可能的答案来阻止这样做。技术正在进步。这不是一套身份不明的遗骸。实验室技术人员告诉五角大楼
that new DNA-based technology was being developed that would allow the remains to be conclusively identified. They also pointed to the artifacts, like the flight suit and the life raft, and a record of the missing wallet, all of which suggested that their remains were most likely glasses. But the push to put a Vietnam unknown in the tomb overrode that, and a general from the army was sent to tell them, everybody better get the hell out of the way.
正在开发基于DNA的新技术，这将使遗骸能够被最终识别。他们还指出了文物，如飞行服和救生筏，以及丢失钱包的记录，所有这些都表明他们的遗骸很可能是布拉西的。但将一名越南无名者安葬在墓中的推动力压倒了这一点，一名陆军将军被派去告诉他们，最好大家都滚开。
And that's when Michael Blassy went into the tomb. I felt of Americans Memorial Day is a day of ceremony and speeches. Throughout America today we honor the death of our wars. In its when President Reagan, who may not have known that any of this had happened, gave a speech at a burial in Arlington invoking a powerful mystery. Did he marry? Did he have children? Did he look expectantly to return? To a bride? history.
那就是迈克尔·布拉西进入墓地的时候。我曾是美国人，阵亡将士纪念日是一个充满仪式和演讲的日子。今天，整个美国都在缅怀我们战争中的逝者。当里根总统，他可能不知道这一切已经发生，在阿灵顿的葬礼上发表讲话，唤起了一个强大的谜团。他结婚了吗？他有孩子吗？他是否满怀期待地盼望着回到新娘身边？历史。
The file that Vince discovered 13 years later in 1997 showed that there had never been any mystery at all. Armed with the documents, he teamed up with veteran CBS correspondent Eric Engberg. They talked to anyone they could find who was involved in the unknown selection process. And when they felt they were ready, they presented their findings to Patricia Blasey. And I asked my mom to call a family meeting. And we sat down and we looked at the documents together. And we discussed, you know, what should we do? Patricia wanted to go public with Vince and CBS. Her older sister Judy, if anything, was even more eager to blow the lid off the whole thing.
文斯在13年后的1997年发现的文件显示，根本没有任何谜团。带着这些文件，他与资深哥伦比亚广播公司记者埃里克·恩格伯合作。他们与他们能找到的任何参与无名者挑选过程的人交谈。当他们觉得准备好后，他们向帕特里夏·布拉西展示了他们的发现。我请妈妈召开家庭会议。我们坐下来，一起看了这些文件。我们讨论了，你知道，我们应该做什么？帕特里夏想和文斯及哥伦比亚广播公司公开这件事。她的大姐朱迪，如果说有什么不同的话，甚至更渴望揭开这一切的盖子。
But George, the youngest brother, Boked. Michael was buried in a place of honor, he pointed out. Maybe he could stay there and serve as the unknown for everyone else who's loved to ones and never come back. But the tiebreaker was Michael's mother, Jean. She's a very, it was a very patient woman and she listened to all of the opinions
但最小的弟弟乔治，表示反对。迈克尔被安葬在一个荣誉之地，他指出。也许他可以留在那儿，作为所有那些爱的人再也没有回来的人的“无名者”。但打破僵局的是迈克尔的母亲，琼。她是一个非常、非常耐心的女人，她听取了所有意见
of her children, her living children and waited until we were done with our banterine or whatever, and she just looked at us and she said, I want to bring my son home. This is the CBS Evening News. Tonight the results of an Ion America investigation lasting over half a year. Is it possible the government knows the identity of a Vietnam war casualty buried at the tomb of the unknowns in Arlington National Cemetery, but deliberately kept its secret from the public and even his own family? A seven-month CBS news investigation has found evidence of a long-running cover-up.
她的孩子们，她活着的孩子们，等到我们结束了我们的闲聊或什么的，她只是看着我们说，我想带我的儿子回家。这是哥伦比亚广播公司晚间新闻。今晚，一项持续了半年多的“美国之音”调查的结果。政府是否知道安葬在阿灵顿国家公墓无名战士墓中的越战伤亡人员的身份，但故意向公众甚至他的家人隐瞒了秘密？一项为期七个月的哥伦比亚广播公司新闻调查发现了长期掩盖真相的证据。
What followed wasn't just one story on the evening news. It was more like a blizzard of stories. There are significant new developments tonight in the exclusive story that CBS used first broke on this broadcast in January. CBS's Vince Gonzalez uncovered new evidence and update tonight of our exclusive Ion America investigation. I think we did 15 or 18 pieces on this. It just was non-stop. And
随后的不仅仅是晚间新闻中的一个故事。这更像是一场故事的暴风雪。今晚，哥伦比亚广播公司在1月份首次在此广播中报道的独家新闻有了重大新进展。哥伦比亚广播公司的文斯·冈萨雷斯发现了新的证据，今晚更新了我们独家的“美国之音”调查。我想我们为此做了15或18篇报道。这简直是没完没了。而且
tonight is Eric Ngber tells us there's more. Because CBS and the Blassy family didn't just want the world to know that Michael Blassy was in the tomb. They wanted the Pentagon to do something about it. Michael Blassy's sister Pat says the family wants the remains tested even if by some chance they aren't identified as Michael. Now Congress wants to investigate. If it's Michael, we want to bring him home. At a certain point, they called us up and they said, you're killin' us.
今晚，正如埃里克·恩格伯告诉我们的，还有更多。因为哥伦比亚广播公司和布拉西一家不仅想让世界知道迈克尔·布拉西在墓里。他们想让五角大楼对此采取行动。迈克尔·布拉西的妹妹帕特说，家人希望对遗骸进行检测，即使万一他们没有被确认为迈克尔。现在国会想要调查。如果是迈克尔，我们想带他回家。在某个时候，他们打电话给我们说，你们快把我们逼疯了。
And day or two later, they announced the tomb would be opened and the remains were going to be tested. On May 14, 1998, the Department of Defense disinterred the remains of the Vietnam veteran from the tomb of the unknown soldier. DNA samples were taken from Michael's mother Jane and his sister Judy and tested against the remains. They were a match. And after the scientists were finished talking to my mother, we were wrapping things up because my mother had to sign some papers and things like that. And then all of a sudden a man walked
一两天后，他们宣布墓穴将被打开，遗骸将接受检测。1998年5月14日，国防部从无名战士墓中起出了这位越战老兵的遗骸。他们提取了迈克尔母亲简和妹妹朱迪的DNA样本，并与遗骸进行了比对。结果吻合。科学家们与我母亲谈完后，我们正准备收尾，因为我母亲还需要签署一些文件之类的东西。突然，一个人走了过来，
up and said, well, when we opened the tomb to do the DNA test, Michael's artifacts were in the tomb with him. And what would you like us to do with them? The life raft and other items had been found at the crash in 1972 had been the only physical evidence aside from the missing wallet that could have tied the remains to Michael Blassy. Whether it was to preserve the artifacts or to hide them. Someone at the Army Lab in Hawaii had put them where no one would ever think to look in the casket with Michael. They had been sitting in the tomb underneath the guards and the crowds and the Arlington soil for 14 years.
说，嗯，当我们打开墓穴进行DNA检测时，迈克尔的遗物和他在一起。你们想怎么处理这些东西？1972年在坠机现场发现的救生筏和其他物品，除了那个失踪的钱包外，是唯一能将遗骸与迈克尔·布拉西联系起来的物证。无论是为了保存这些文物还是为了隐藏它们，夏威夷陆军实验室的某个人把它们放在了没人会想到的地方——迈克尔的棺材里。它们在守卫、人群和阿灵顿的泥土下静静地躺了14年。
They were in a box and so after we buried Michael in St. Louis. There was a reception and then once everyone left. We stood around the table and my brother George opened up the box and started pulling out the life raft, portions of his parachute, portions of his flight suit. And I have him with me today. I keep him with me. But I was really glad to have them. Today, there is no body representing Vietnam at the tomb of the unknowns.
它们装在一个盒子里，所以我们在圣路易斯安葬了迈克尔之后，举行了招待会。等大家都走了，我们围在桌子旁，我哥哥乔治打开盒子，开始拿出救生筏、部分降落伞和部分飞行服。今天我把它们带在身边。我一直把它们带在身边。但我真的很高兴能拥有它们。今天，无名战士墓中已经没有代表越南的遗骸了。
And thanks to improved forensics, there will likely never be an unknown from Iraq, or Afghanistan, or any future war. The military is now in the process of using the DNA from the families of missing veterans to identify over 650 sets of unknown remains from the Korean War. It's conceivable that they could use the same techniques
多亏了法医技术的进步，未来可能再也不会有来自伊拉克、阿富汗或任何未来战争的无名战士了。军方目前正在利用失踪老兵家属的DNA，对朝鲜战争中650多具无名遗骸进行身份鉴定。可以想象，他们可能会使用同样的技术
on the Korean unknown inside the tomb. The unknowns from World War I and World War II are safe for now, but in the era of 23 and me, well, let's just say anything's possible. If you go to Arlington today, the tomb of the unknowns is still there, minus the remains for Vietnam. The tourists still take pictures on their phones, and the guards still make their rounds in perfect,
对墓中的朝鲜战争无名战士进行鉴定。第一次世界大战和第二次世界大战的无名战士目前还很安全，但在“23andMe”基因检测时代，嗯，只能说一切皆有可能。如果你今天去阿灵顿，无名战士墓依然在那里，只是少了越战的那具遗骸。游客们仍然用手机拍照，守卫们依然以完美、
silent precision. Day and night, even when no one is watching. And it really is beautiful. You should go see it. But the heyday of this unique form of remembrance has come to an end. Does that sadden you? Like does it sadden you that there is no unknown for Vietnam anymore? I can't say that it saddens me. I can't say that it saddens me.
静谧的精准度进行巡逻。日日夜夜，即使在无人注视时也是如此。这真的很美。你应该去看看。但这种独特的纪念形式的鼎盛时期已经结束了。这让你感到难过吗？比如，越战不再有无名战士，这让你感到难过吗？我不能说这让我难过。我不能说这让我难过。
I can't say that. I respect the timidly unknowns. But in order to have an unknown, they made one. They took Michael's name away from him. To satisfy something that I understand was very important to our nation. But the first thing that you and I did when we met one another over the phone Hi, I'm Patricia or I'm Pat. Hi, I'm Joe. A name is very, very important.
我不能那样说。我尊重无名战士。但为了拥有一个“无名”，他们制造了一个。他们剥夺了迈克尔的名字。为了满足我认为对我们国家非常重要的事情。但你我在电话里第一次交谈时做的第一件事就是：你好，我是帕特里夏，或者我是帕特。你好，我是乔。名字是非常、非常重要的。
Patricia still visits the tomb. She says she's not sure why she does it, but it means that she's gotten to know some of the guards. One of them once told her that their mission, guarding the unknowns, is never really over. But that in Michael's case, just this once, their mission was completed. They were just looking out for him, until he could go home. Joe talks me through the very precise ceremony that has evolved at the tomb of the unknown.
帕特里夏仍然会去墓地。她说她不确定自己为什么要去，但这让她认识了一些守卫。其中一人曾告诉她，他们守卫无名战士的使命永远不会真正结束。但在迈克尔的案例中，仅此一次，他们的使命完成了。他们只是在守护他，直到他能回家。乔向我详细介绍了在无名战士墓演变出的非常精确的仪式。
After this. Okay, Roman. So when I was a little kid, my parents, and I think my grandparents who lived just outside of Washington, DC, they took me to Arlington, Cemetery to see the tomb of the unknown soldier. And I remember it really well, and I have to say the reason I remember it so well, and the reason I became interested in the tomb again more recently is not the mysterious soldier in the tomb projecting whatever you want onto his anonymity.
稍后继续。好的，罗曼。所以当我还是个小孩子的时候，我的父母，我想还有住在华盛顿特区郊外的祖父母，带我去了阿灵顿公墓看无名战士墓。我记得很清楚，我必须说我记得这么清楚的原因，以及我最近再次对这座墓产生兴趣的原因，并不是因为墓中那个神秘的士兵，让你对他匿名身份产生任何联想。
It's actually the guard. And it's not so much the idea of the guard keeping vigil like this solemn duty as much as it is what the guard is physically doing. And what they're doing most of the time is just taking 21 steps to the left, turning, stopping for 21 seconds, then turning and stopping for another 21 seconds, then taking 21 steps to the right, then stopping again, turning again, stopping again, stepping again, over and over and over, until there's a guard change every 30 minutes to an hour.
其实是守卫。与其说是守卫像这种庄严职责一样守夜，不如说是守卫在身体上所做的事情。他们大部分时间都在做的事情就是向左走21步，转身，停顿21秒，然后转身再停顿21秒，然后向右走21步，然后再次停顿，再次转身，再次停顿，再次迈步，一遍又一遍，直到每30分钟到一个小时进行一次换岗。
That sounds very, very precise. Yeah, and actually, that's the thing, he's like, you say that, but you have no life Let me sell you on this by just showing you a video of what this looks like. This is from a guard change Nice design touch. The stripes on the legs really sell the synchronization. So as regimented as I was imagining it, it is even more so. It is like the innards of a Swiss clock, the way that they move together and then they move in time is stunning.
听起来非常、非常精确。是的，事实上，就是这样，他就像，你说得对，但你没有生活。让我给你展示一段视频，看看这是什么样子，以此来说服你。这是换岗仪式。不错的设计细节。腿上的条纹确实体现了同步性。所以，正如我所想象的那样严谨，甚至有过之而无不及。他们移动的方式就像瑞士钟表的内部零件，他们一起移动，然后同步移动，真是令人惊叹。
Yeah, no. And one of the things I kind of really appreciate it is just the way, like, if you have like a Swiss clock that is kind of ticking away with precision, it hasn't this way of magnifying the silence around it. There's a kind of weird silence to it. And apparently, to get this right, they train and practice for months in a separate facility. Wow. And it's almost meditative. Like you said, like inside of the silence, when you hear the clicking of their shoes and their heels together, you do get this space that's created inside of it that's very meditative. The word that just instantly came to mind is like zen.
是的，没错。我真正欣赏的一点是，如果你有一个像瑞士钟表那样精准走时的东西，它有一种放大周围寂静的方式。有一种奇怪的寂静感。显然，为了做到这一点，他们在单独的设施里训练和练习了几个月。哇。这几乎是冥想式的。就像你说的，在寂静中，当你听到他们鞋子和脚后跟撞击的声音时，你确实会在其中创造出一个非常冥想的空间。脑海中立刻浮现出的词是“禅”。
You watch the marching back and forth and the guards when they're doing it, they don't seem lost in the performance. Instead, at every step, they are totally present. They are completely aware of their surroundings. They are truly doing nothing but this. Unless you start laughing. Oh. It is requested that all visitors
你看着他们来回走动，守卫们在做这些动作时，似乎并没有沉浸在表演中。相反，每走一步，他们都完全处于当下。他们完全意识到周围的环境。他们确实什么都没做，只是在做这件事。除非你开始大笑。哦。要求所有游客
maintain an atmosphere of silence and respect at all times. Hopefully, Moly. I don't want to cross that guy at all. No, it's really terrifying. It just bursts out of nowhere. This is what happens if you get too rowdy or you laugh at the tomb of the unknown. There's more. There's this whole subgenre of YouTube videos of like tomb guards yelling at yelling at
始终保持安静和尊重的氛围。天哪，莫莉。我一点也不想惹那个家伙。不，这真的很可怕。它突然从虚无中爆发出来。如果你在无名战士墓前太吵闹或大笑，就会发生这种情况。还有更多。YouTube上有一整个子类型的视频，都是关于墓地守卫对着游客大喊大叫的。
visitors. Oh, good. they deserve it. Oh yeah, let's hear it. So like, let's find another one. They've requested it all for you to remain behind the change of rail. It's requested it all for you to remain behind the change of rails. It's like, and like, but they can just vary it up. They can like vary their tone.
哦，太好了。他们活该。哦，是的，让我们听听。所以，让我们再找一个。他们要求你们所有人保持在换岗线后面。他们要求你们所有人保持在换岗线后面。就像，他们可以改变语气。他们可以改变他们的语调。
They can switch up the words a little bit. I think it depends on the guard. It depends on there. Maybe they're mood that day. The holy moly. So here's a mo, here's a mo words a little bit. I think it depends on the the guard. It depends on there Maybe they're mood that day Holy moly, so here's it. Here's a moor curt one Oh, I love it. Just let them have it and this is this is one where they they Reprimand some parents Visitors must keep their children behind the great trains and rails
他们可以稍微改变一下措辞。我认为这取决于守卫。取决于他们。也许是他们那天的心情。天哪，所以这里有一个，这里有一个……措辞稍微改变了一下。我认为这取决于守卫。取决于他们。也许是他们那天的心情。天哪，所以这里有一个。这里有一个更生硬的。哦，我喜欢。让他们发泄出来，这是一个他们训斥一些家长的视频。游客必须让他们的孩子待在护栏后面。
Thank you Little Billy being y yanks back real fast. That happened to me. There's other videos where you see like people trying to sneak in, like kind of behind the rails, you like you get a view of them, and then they're yelled at, and then they just like, they freeze like, like chipmunks who've been like, caught, you know, out in the open, and then just like, just bolted it like they're just terrifying. And then just like just bolt and it's terrifying. My favorite comment though is from a YouTube user who said, and I quote, when I was 10 years old, I made the mistake of sitting down during the changing
谢谢。小比利被猛地拉了回来。那也发生在我身上。还有其他视频，你可以看到人们试图偷偷溜到护栏后面，你看到了他们，然后他们被大声呵斥，然后他们就像被抓个正着的花栗鼠一样僵住了，你知道，在光天化日之下，然后就像，只是逃跑了，这太可怕了。然后就像只是逃跑了，这太可怕了。不过我最喜欢的评论来自一位YouTube用户，他说，引用一下，“当我10岁的时候，我犯了一个错误，在换岗时坐了下来，我差点吓尿了。”所以。还有其他国家纪念碑有这样的东西吗？有这种24小时全天候的仪式，为什么偏偏在这里发生？嗯，是的，这是一个好问题，因为关于这座墓，现在的样子并不是它一直以来的样子。它演变成所有这些排场、仪式
of the guards and I almost shat myself. So. Does any other national monument have something like this, where there's this 24, seven ritual, why in particular is that that happening right here? Well, yeah, I mean, that's a good question because the thing about the tomb is that like the way it is now is not the way it always was. It evolved into all of this kind of pomp and ceremony
和奇观，是在1921年首次纪念它的时候。那是一个重要的时刻。我想这是总统发表的第一次全国广播讲话，就是在无名战士墓的纪念仪式上。但那时它只是一块低矮的石板。没有宏伟的建筑之类的东西。它在一段时间内变成了一个二流的纪念碑。人们会在那里野餐。摄影师会，
and spectacle when it was first commemorated in 1921. It was a big moment. I think it was the first nationwide radio address that the president ever gave was from the commemoration of the tomb of the unknown. But back then it was just kind of this low stone slab. There was no big edifice or anything like that. And it kind of became a second-rate monument for a while. People would picnic there. And photographers would like,
因为它在山上，可以很好地俯瞰周围地区。摄影师实际上会在那里摆摊，人们会像在墓上摆姿势。几乎就像一个路边景点。人们，但显然老兵们发现了这一点，并开始抱怨，因为他们看到人们只是把它当作……
cause it has a great view of the surrounding area cause it's up on this hill. And photographers would actually kind of set up shop there and people would like pose on the tomb. Almost like just kind of like a roadside attraction. And people, but apparently like veterans caught on to this and started complaining about it cause they saw that kind of people were just treating it.
是的，就像娱乐一样，他们会在上面掐灭香烟，诸如此类的事情。所以他们向国会投诉，最终政府凑钱雇了一名守卫。从1937年开始，守卫就是24小时全天候的。我见过关于此的相互矛盾的记录，有的说自1937年以来，有的说自1948年以来，守卫从未离开过。
Yeah, like entertainment and they were like kind of putting out their cigarettes on it, things like that. And so they kind of complained about it to Congress and eventually the government cobbled together the money to post a guard. And then starting in 1937, the guard was 24-7. And I've seen competing records on this once some say since 1937, others say since 1948, the guard has never left.
即使是飓风期间，它也一直存在。在那段时间里发生的另一件事是，他们一直打算建一座更现代、更华丽的墓，但筹集资金花了好长时间。所以他们在1931年建造了那种巨大的石棺。为此，他们去了科罗拉多州的一个采石场，以确保他们得到与林肯纪念堂完全相同的大理石。虽然它不是由这些人设计的，但它是雕刻的，实际的物理雕刻是由一对著名的兄弟完成的，叫皮科雷利兄弟，
Even for hurricanes, it's state there. And then the other thing that happened during that time is that they always intended for there to be like a more updated fancy tomb, but it just took them forever to get around to getting the funding. And so they built the kind of the giants sarcophagus in 1931. And for that, they went to this quarry in Colorado, actually, to ensure that they got the exact same marble as the Lincoln Memorial. And although it wasn't designed by these guys, it was sculpted, like the actual physical sculpting is by this famous set of brothers called the Pico-Rele brothers,
他们是意大利兄弟，雕刻了一切。他们雕刻了林肯纪念堂，我最喜欢的是他们雕刻了纽约公共图书馆门前的两只狮子。哇。然后，在1956年，我们开始增加来自第二次世界大战、朝鲜战争等的无名战士。
were these Italian brothers who who sculpted like everything. They sculpted the Lincoln Memorial, and my favorite is they sculpted the two lions in front of the New York City Public Library. Wow. And then, in 1956, that's when we started adding these further unknowns from World War II, Korea, et cetera.
是的。所以就这样一点点建立起来。变成了一个越来越庄严的地方。当你这样看它时，它有一种近乎永恒传统的形象，但我实际上很喜欢这样一个事实，即这是一个经过迭代、改进，并且随着时间的推移被赋予了更多分量的事物。我加倍欣赏它，因为我喜欢那种朝着简洁和优雅方向迭代的事物，而不是那种感觉像杂乱无章的迭代。变得更随意之类的。这是一个迷人的地方，特别是由于这个仪式，
Yeah. So just built and built and built. Into this more and more reverent place. It has the image of an almost timeless tradition when you see it like this, but I actually kind of enjoy the fact that this is something that was, you know, iterated upon and improved and, you know, given a little more weight over time. I doubly appreciate it because I love when something's iterative in the direction of honing towards austerity and elegance, as opposed to iterative and feeling like clutter. Getting more casual or something like that. It's a fascinating place, particularly because of this ceremony,
使它更加特别。你在报道时有没有机会和其中一名守卫交谈？我承认，我没能及时联系到守卫来完成这个尾声。我有更重要的事情要做，对吧？我完全不会输。这是一个20年的谜团，所以。但我得到了次好的东西，那就是我发现其中一名守卫，当然，我得到了次好的东西，那就是我发现其中一名守卫，当然，做了一个Reddit的“问我任何事”。这就是我所说的。这是一个快速链接。所以，当然，当你是一名记者，看到一个“问我任何事”
makes it all the more special. Have you ever had a chance to speak to one of the guards when you do in the reporting? I confess, I did not manage to reach a guard in time for this Coda. I'd bigger fish to fry, right? I totally don't lose. There was a 20-year mystery, so. But I got the next best thing, which is I found that one of the guards did, of course, I got the next best thing, which is I found that one of the guards did, of course, a Reddit ask me anything. That's what I was saying. It's an express link. And so, of course, one of the things is like, when you're a reporter and you see and ask me anything
帖子时，你会浏览它，希望有人会问你想问的问题。我唯一想问的问题是，当你来回走动时，你的脑子里在想什么？特别不是在换岗期间，而是在漫长的30分钟或一小时里，来回走动，特别不是在换岗期间，而是在漫长的30分钟或一小时里，在那种冥想状态下走来走去，对吧？所以最后，有人问了这个问题，对吧？守卫回答说，我希望我能说，当我们做这份工作时，我们只是在冥想，思考守卫无名战士意味着什么，但我们是人，我们正在值班
thread, you're like, you go through it, hoping someone's going to ask like the question you would ask. And the only question I wanted to ask is like, what is going through your head when you are marching back and forth, and that's particularly not during the change in the guard, but just during the long, 30 minutes, or the long hour, marching back and forth, and that's particularly not during the changing of the guard, but just during the long, 30 minutes of the long hour, but marching back and forth during this like meditative state, right? And so finally, someone like asked this, right? And the guard responded, I wish I could say that while we were doing this job, we are just meditating, what it means to guard the unknowns, but we are human and we are on duty
很长时间。所以我们的思绪确实会飘忽不定，这读起来太令人失望了。哦，但这真的很人性化。我知道。我知道，但讽刺的是，我意识到当我在做这个故事时，我想，哦，人们可以自由地将他们想要的任何东西投射到无名战士的神秘感上。这当然是我那种非常自负的套路，认为，我
for long hours. So our minds do wander quite a bit, which was so disappointing to read. Oh, but it's really human. I know. I know, but here's the irony, which is like I realized that when I was doing the story, and I was like, oh, people are free to project whatever they want onto the mystery of the unknown soldier. That's of course my repertoire way of being really conceited and thinking, like, I'm
高于这一点，我不会陷入投射任何东西的陷阱。我不是那么简单。但当我看到守卫的那一刻，我想，我想看到什么？我是一名来自旧金山的99%可见度节目的记者。我看到了禅宗冥想，对吧？这立刻就是我投射到这个家伙身上的东西，对吧？然后，当然，在“问我任何事”的帖子中，他只是说，不，不，不，我们的思绪会飘忽不定。
above that and I don't fall prey to projecting anything. I'm not too simpleism. But the minute I see the guard, I'm like, what do I want to see? Like, I'm a reporter at 99% visible who lives in San Francisco. I see like zen meditation, right? Like, it's immediately what I project onto this guy, right? And then, of course, like, in the asking me anything throughout, he's just like, no, no, no, our minds wander.
我们想任何事情，我们要去吃什么晚餐，谁知道呢，对吧？所以你知道，我想，这座墓也对我施了魔法。是的，谢谢你，乔。好的。谢谢你，罗曼。99%可见度本周由乔·罗森伯格制作，凯蒂·曼格尔编辑，谢雷夫·优素福混音，斯旺·里亚尔配乐。特别感谢卢·彭内贝克和安迪·理查兹，他们的采访没有被收录，但没有他们的帮助，这个故事就不可能发生。我们特别感谢安迪·理查兹的书《旗帜》。这是大卫·雷尔顿的传记，他是第一个提出无名战士墓想法的牧师。
We think about whatever, what we're going to dinner who knows right and so you know, I guess The the the tomb is worked its magic on me as well. Yeah, thank you, Joe. All right. Thank you Roman 99% of Ismael was produced this week by Joe Rosenberg, edited by Katie Mangle, mixed by Sherefusif, music by Swan Rial. Special thanks to Lou Pennebaker and Andy Richards, whose interviews were not featured, but without whose help this story could not have happened. We're especially indebted to Andy Richards' book The Flag. It's a biography of David Railton, the clergyman who first came up with the idea of the tomb of the unknown warrior.
网站上有气泡链接。99%可见度的执行制片人是凯西·图。我们的高级编辑是莱恩·霍尔，库尔特·科尔斯特是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·迪利恩、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、马丁·冈萨雷斯、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·李、拉什莫顿、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳、凯利·普莱姆，还有我，罗曼·马斯。99%可见度的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作的。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼。在美丽的。
Bubble Link on the website. 99% of visible is executive producer is Cathy too. Our senior editor is Lene Hall, Kurt Colestet is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason Dillion, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Martín Gonzales, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lashmodon, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Kelly Prime, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of his below-go was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心，你们的奥克兰根基足球俱乐部的所在地，我是该俱乐部的骄傲社区所有者。随着其他职业球队的离开，奥克兰根基队永远是奥克兰第一。你可以访问所有常见的社交媒体网站，但我们确实要求你始终保持安静和尊重的氛围。你可以找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，
Uptown, Oakland, California, home of your Oakland Roots soccer club, of which I'm a proud community owner. As other professional teams leave, the Oakland Roots are Oakland first, always. You can visit all the usual social media sites, but we do request you maintain an atmosphere of silence and respect at all times. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love,
以及99PI的每一集往期节目，网址是9ipeyod.org。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
as well as every past episode of 99PI at 9ipeyod.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及99PI的所有往期节目，请访问99pi.org。目前本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。